every family we spoke to In This fishing
Village has lost a son a father or both
more than a hundred people many of them
young men set sail from here more than a
month ago most of them won't come back
two people from Iden Yang's family are
missing her sons among the survivors
when he called her from a hospital in
Cape Verde she says he was too weak to
explain what happened
but she says she understands why he took
the perilous trip she's looking after
his two-year-old son as she waits and
hopes he'll make it home
the only work in this place is fishing
these days the young people are going to
see and not catching much because
foreign vessels are taking it all they
have to support their mother and their
children that's why they want to go to
Europe so they can send some money to
their families
is the same fishing boats that provided
a livelihood for Generations past that a
growing number of young people here hope
will take them to a brighter future
the 600 kilometer Voyage to Cape Verde
is on the way to the Spanish Canary
Islands
it's a risky route to the European Union
dozens of shipwrecks are reported every
year and hundreds of deaths an unknown
number go on recorded the boat was like
this one made of wood and people here
say normally it takes no more than seven
days of sailing out into the Atlantic
Ocean to reach Cape Verde they say when
they realize that this boat was in
trouble they reported it to the
authorities here in Senegal who they say
did nothing didn't launch a rescue
operation and it was more than a month
after the boat set off when they finally
learned the fate of those on board
when the news reached here that Cape
verde's Coast Guard had found the boat
but most had not survived people blocked
the roads with burning barricades
The Village Chief told us that migrants
from all over the region have been
leaving here in boats since 2006 but
this is the first tragedy of its kind to
affect people from this community
the youth demonstrated because the
governments failed to do anything about
irregular migration those who departed
had been reported as stranded at sea but
it was Spanish fishermen that eventually
saw them and raised the alarm they've
asked the government to help the people
of this place but there's no investment
and there are a few jobs
the way
riot police arrived after dark and
cleared the streets
several families told us they kicked in
doors in the middle of the night and
arrested about 20 people most of them
teenage boys
didn't respond to our request for
comment
there's no shortage of reasons here
for young people to risk it all
Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera fast boy Senegal